[Applaus]
truppenübungsplatz auf der steirischen
seite
nach fünfjähriger planung und umsetzung
wird am dienstag das neue heizhaus
eröffnet für kommandant manfred hofer
fühlt sich dieser tag fast so an wie ein
sieg bei den us open
er würde ja seit vergleichen mit dem
sieg von dominic thiem aber natürlich
ist es für uns ein großer feiertag dass
dieses biomasseheizwerk heute eröffnet
worden ist
wir sind froh dass es noch so langen
vorbereitungen endlich soweit gekommen
ist die benötigte energie liefern dem
truppenübungsplatz ab sofort nur mehr
sonne und hackschnitzeln 200.000 liter
heizöl pro jahr werden eingespart wir
sind jetzt völlig autark das holz
bekommen wir von unserem
truppenübungsplatz beziehung so von
anderen waldgebieten die dem
österreichischen bundesheer gehören das
ist der entscheidende punkt hier gerade
im bereich der biomasse
es ist schon gesagt worden wie nahe hier
unser rohstoff ist wie klar und deutlich
hier auch co2 einsparung passieren kann
und wie sinnvoll das auch im kontext
eines gesamten klimaschutzprogramm es
ist es glaube ich hier sehr klar auch
gezeigt dass neue kraftwerk versorgt
alle gebäude je nach bedarf und das
bringt viele vorteile
nicht nur dass wir energie effizienter
aufgestellt sind sondern durch die neue
regelungstechnik in den unterkünften
können wir sicherstellen dass eine
optimale temperatur führte soldaten
herrscht wir können auch hier energie
sparen indem wir nicht belegte räume
entsprechend in der wärme reduzieren und
belegte räume nach den wünschen der
soldaten hier einstellen können dass
gerade die steiermark bei solchen
projekten oft eine vorreiterrolle
einnimmt ist für den militärkommandanten
keine überraschung die steuerbarkeit
sich schon immer als innovativ gezeigt
und mit innovativen kommandanten und
innovativen ideen konnten wir immer
realisieren und außerdem gibt es noch
ein erfolgsgeheimnis ich habe allen der
solche projekte machen
nur eines empfehlen immer am drücker der
zeit bleiben um immer lästig werden und
nicht den weg nach wien zu schauen
[Applaus]